the i-team broke this story five days
ago and no leader from unlv has agreed
to an interview not the president not
the board of regents with regard to
the university
having knowledge of this and accepting
and allowing this well go speak with the
university and the board of regents
they got a lot of explaining to do in my
opinion
they cannot duck hide bob and weave on
this chairman stephen klubeck says the
nevada state athletic commission will
investigate this fraternity boxing match
held on november 19th kappa sigma
fraternity held the event according to
social media posts nathan valencia
participated for charity he's seen in
this red headgear he collapsed after his
fight and died four days later from head
injuries we're here to uncover the facts
klubeck says the athletic commission has
no jurisdiction over the event the
i-team uncovered why as of 1985 contests
of unarmed combat conducted by or
participated by a school or university
were ex
did a fraternity boxing match result in
the death of a unlv study
his family says they're going to be
holding those responsible accountable
and today we learned there will be an
investigation by the athletic commission
and it's a story the i-team's vanessa
murphy first broke she has more as she
tries to get answers
the i-team broke this story five days
ago and no leader from unlv has agreed
to an interview not the president not
the board of regents with regard to
the university
having knowledge of this and accepting
and allowing this well go speak with the
university and the board of regents
they got a lot of explaining to do in my
opinion
um they cannot duck hide bob and weave
on this chairman stephen klubeck says
the nevada state athletic commission
will investigate this fraternity boxing
match held on november 19th kappa sigma
fraternity held the event according to
social media posts nathan valencia
participated for charity he's seen in
this red headgear he collapsed after his
fight and died four days later from head
injuries we're here to uncover the facts
klubeck says the athletic commission has
no jurisdiction over the event the
i-team uncovered why as of 1985 contests
of unarmed combat conducted by or
participated by a school or university
were excluded from the commission's
oversight we need to get to the bottom
of what happened and make sure that it
certainly never happens again on tuesday
governor steve siselek addressed the
deadly fight it is a tragedy and i'm
sorry for the family the young man was
trying to do something good through his
fraternity for nonprofit i spoke to the
chair of the athletic commission i've
spoken to the chancellor about this
there are numerous investigations
underway here's what the i-team has
uncovered so far witnesses reporting no
medical help on standby at the event
valencia's family saying this referee
wasn't a professional video which
appears to show him drinking alcohol
that night and also looking at the
judge's table frequently head gear
repeatedly needing to be adjusted
and moments when hall of fame boxing ref
richard steele says valencia's fight
should have been stopped he's showing he
don't want to be there when he turns
away anytime i see a fighter
turn away from the fight the fight is
over students who were there tell the
i-team the event was chaotic nothing was
organized from the head gear to
the referee everybody was hitting each
other in the back of their heads we've
received statements from the kappa sigma
fraternity metro police and valencia's
family the family says they've learned
other students who have participated in
the event in previous years were knocked
unconscious and had to be hospitalized
we'll have all of the full statements at
8newsnow.com
vanessa murphy live local now